dans un bref
pas
[Musique]
non bonjour je m'appelle jocelyne
beroard et je vais vous faire le titre
attendre je vous retrouve tout de suite
après
[Musique]
on
ton
[Musique]
j'ai vu
manseng
actuellement huit leur quart monde
fini disait douter
[Musique]
attends
ce timo
ça
[Musique]
les sens
selon moscou
le
andré lapointe
utah
pour
on l'a
oh
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
roudier
rétro
[Musique]
à temps
non
ça
diffèrent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
oui bon
vivre
[Musique]
ans
je tends
[Musique]
deux mois
moi
[Applaudissements]
ou deux
[Musique]
ans
d
[Musique]
quand
l'année
jours
[Applaudissements]
comment venir
1 me
[Musique]
je choisis le titre attendent d'abord
parce que c'est un site qu'on ne connaît
pas beaucoup de moi je l'interprète
rarement il a été composé par henri
salvador et j'ai écrit le texte et le
texte je les écris en pensant à ma vie
de femme artiste en fait quand on est
femme artiste comparativement aux hommes
c'est nous qui rentre on tard
et ça tous les ans n'accepte pas
toujours et quand nous rentrons quelques
jours après nous ne sommes pas toujours
c'est afin de retrouver le bonhomme à la
maison donc c'est une chanson qui dit
tout simplement à temps j'arrive
tarifs 8 attends moi voilà
[Applaudissements]
non
coup de
[Musique]
merci beaucoup on se retrouve bientôt
peut-être
[Musique]
pour moi